the so-called islamic state has launched
the largest scale attack in syria since
it was defeated there in 2019 their
target a prison holding jihadists in the
northeast and the kurdish-led syrian
democratic forces say they've repelled
the attackers and recaptured all or most
of the inmates who'd escaped in the
chaos
24 hours after the initial onslaught the
neighborhoods around gueyeron prison
were still a battleground
conflicting reports of numbers of dead
fighters and civilians hung over the
city like the plumes of smoke from
explosions
almost 100 suspected is fighters managed
to escape from the prison
these kurdish security forces prepared
for combat
we're now going into the basel
roundabout where there's about 300
islamic state fighters coming out
we'll be facing them and turning them
back to where they came from we'll make
them regret what they did
they're killing and trying to win but
we're here to stop them
hundreds of residents with homes near
the prison fled the fighting
some of them eyewitnesses to the
bloodshed
there's been bombing and warplanes since
yesterday and young people were
slaughtered
what is happening the situation is
catastrophic we got scared for our
children and fled
there's been shelling and killing since
yesterday
s killed four or five people in our
neighborhood
this footage allegedly shows fugitives
who were recaptured by kurdish forces
human rights organizations have
criticized the kurdish authorities for
the inhumane conditions in its prisons
with overcrowding rampant and due
process often denied to suspected is
militants
the growing resentment toward the
kurdish-led administration could help is
grow its ranks
the group once controlled swathes of
syria and iraq but was driven out by a
coalition of u.s kurdish and iraqi
forces in 2019
just hours after the attack in syria
began is gunmen assaulted this army base
in central iraq
military officials say the insurgents
killed 11 soldiers as they slept
the two attacks show that is once again
ready to pull off large-scale attacks on
both sides of the border
for more i'm now joined by mahmoud
sheikh ibrahim he's a freelance
journalist based in arabil iraq welcome
to the program mahmoud what are you
hearing now about the situation on the
ground in syria after this attack
yeah good morning thus
just this morning the clashes resumed
about 5 30 early morning it resumed
again
and as you know since yesterday the
clashes were started about
the night before at about 8 00
p.m at local time and
the estimated number of the attacker of
isis sells about 100
armed men they started their uh attack
with a car bomb started the the gate of
the prison
and when we talk about this prison it's
not a normal prison it's just a
makeshift prison it was a
industrial vocational
secondary school in the past and after
2019 they turned it into be
a prison or a jail for isis a thousand
of isis fighters who surrounded after
bhagot's battle
so the situation is
sorry
no i was just going to ask you you said
that it was a makeshift prison what kind
of security then did it have because as
we saw this was quite a brazen attack
actually they are the the
intensity the guarding
process and the coalition was helping
with the
air watching and air support but this is
not the first time to be this happened
in this prison or the makeshift prison
it happened it's maybe the 12th or the
11th time this time but this is the
biggest deadly attack on the prison and
the biggest operation after the
eliminate the
so-called islamic state
so they were depending on guarding and
depending on such human things not that
technical or complete
process can you talk to us a little bit
about some of the people who are being
held in this prison we know that there
are some high-ranking is fighters
there yeah uh the this prison contains
about five thousand uh ex-isis fighters
who surrounded the to the sdf after the
baghos battle in 2019
uh among these people there are the
three types of uh
like nationalities syrian local ones and
iraqis and also we have foreign fighters
majority of them are very
talented experienced fighters of isis
and they are very risky ones this is not
the only prison but the main prison in
northeast of syria
mahmoud sheikh ibrahim reporting for us
from arable iraq thank you very much
you are very good
you